okay well thank you thanks to the
organizers thanks for coming to the talk
where all your questions to emit will be
answered so let me just start off with a
definition of Io basically everything I
say today's is going to follow from this
definition amid talked about
constructions so I'm just going to talk
about consequences so
indistinguishability obfuscator is uh
you know it's a an efficient algorithm
that takes as input program and it's an
efficient algorithm it preserves the
functionality of the program in the
sense that the output program has the
same exactly the same input and output
behaviors the original one and it's
obfuscating which in this sense in the
sense of i/o means that essentially it
acts as a pseudo canonicalize err ok so
it provides kind of a canonical a pseudo
canonical form for the program in the
sense that if you start off with two
programs that have exactly the same
input output behavior and you feed it
into the pseudo canonicalize ER you
can't tell which one was obfuscating so
you know it's really gaming the word is
obfuscation itself is kind of a puss
kotori you don't really know what it
means so in this case this is what it
means it just provides a canonical form
against efficient adversaries
so that's the English version and for
the most part i'm going to be talking
about office gating circuit so they will
also address other models of computation
so if you want to do things botanically
which seems to be the thing a theme of
this conference so I'll be sitting right
right here so we have let you know out
on the DI o limb we have a dead playing
in the grass here we also have Benny
who's you know one moment he's working
on it c0 one moment he's working on vbb
I don't know where to find it all right
so I'm going to start off with some
simple applications of I oh just some
kind of layups to convince the doubters
that IO is actually interesting that it
can do stuff all right so here's a first
really great application so you can
prove that an indistinguishability
obfuscator is basically as good as any
other possible obfuscator it's the best
possible Appa skater okay so Goldwasser
and Roth brim prove that and the proof
is a is really simple so you know you
start off with the on the left and the
right side with some program so now
imagine you knew the actual actual best
obfuscation algorithm I mean some really
great option algorithm out there you
happen to know it well you could you
could apply to that program but on the
right side let's just you know you don't
know that best possible that best
obfuscator so you just apply some
padding to get it up to the same size as
the left side so now if you just wrap
indistinguishable any office gation
around these two programs well these two
programs have the same input output
functionality so the security definition
of iosys these two things are
indistinguishable
so what that means is that I mean
obviously this program is is well off
skated on the left side by the best
actual best obfuscator so what that
means is that this on this side you're
off skating just as well even though
initially you only applied some padding
but then you applied this wrapper of
indistinguishability obfuscation make
sense you're saying noting issues of
efficiency this is kind of fun right
because it presumably this bed I mean
for current efficient construction is
getting people to like the size of the
universe so it's I mean if you don't own
this polynomial size of the universe is
fine with me I can yeah thank you okay
so another application is restricted use
software so of you so so the thing that
you said before it only works if the
best spot the best possible thing is
exactly right it preserves functionality
yes yes I mean maybe there's something
you can say about office caters that
only do so approximately for whatever
approximately means but what I was
referring to is exactly yes sir
should one patent program before you
obfuscating them two different provinces
that this is the best possible of
rotation it doesn't seem like that would
make much sense to do that to add
useless padding and then apply your IO
on top of that well I mean yeah I mean
for the proofs to go through I mean just
like the proof for the proof here to go
through yeah you do actually do that I'm
just saying that when you actually think
what is that accomplished i mean i guess
it accomplishes something i mean
certainly in terms of the proof in the
real world i don't know what that
accomplishes maybe there's some people
that think that there's no difference
between the real world and proofs that
we do but ok so another sort of easy
application is restricted use software
so you start off with this really you
know pig of a software object and what
you want to do is to create various
versions of it you want to you know
maybe create a demo version which is
kind of dumb down it has fewer
functionalities you can want to create
multiple tiers of the product that you
sell at different prices and so on and
so forth so writing software is
difficult so if you just actually try to
manually remove functionalities from the
software it's not clear that you'll do
that very well you might still leak a
lot of what you wanted to hide okay but
with i oh you can take a different
approach instead of sort of laborious
lee removing the functionality by hand
you can just provide some sort of
interface around the program that just
sort screens inputs that you don't want
to respond to and you know if this has
the same functionality is what you
intended then these are computationally
indistinguishable
okay for a gaming company how do you use
indistinguishability and then trim them
with their soft bristle it's not about
stolen I'm you're releasing a version of
the software what you want to protect
are very certain high levels in the game
or something like that and yeah so I
don't know I'm not a gaming developer
but I'm just saying if there's some way
that from the outside you can just sort
of screen which inputs you want to
respond to then you can do that using a
distinguishable llaves cash you should
show the left slide again it's not about
hiding what the program does it's about
removing features yeah so I think this
is a kind of the confusion that we had
yesterday where people were just kind of
repeating that it's all about the
functionality so yeah it's about the
functionality but really what you do in
I owe a lot of times is that is you're
removing functionality you start off
with a software program that has
originally all sorts of amazing
functionality built into it you have a
program with an actual PRF key in it
that that for which you can compute all
the PRF is and then what you want to do
is you're going to use put some wrapper
around this and remove the functionality
even though you know Technic technically
that functionality might you know still
be in there somewhere in some sense it's
really about removing functionality in
protecting secrets by doing that
so one of the things which I mean I know
about you know these applications and
solving all the problems in cripta but
one of the things it is initially when
people talk about maybe education
Special Investigations efficient take up
a super fast implementation of something
you so much slower and you know you
don't want to do the corner people to
use your pass thing without knowing what
it is so that's your competitive
advantage speed so use it anyway this
sophistication or something you know in
the future for the dress this particular
cancer that you want to cut how you do
you got something that fast I hide
something are you an apron or you want
to say that you have an implementation
that that's something really fast and
you want to demo that managed to get
something and my thing is like faster
than every competitor in the market and
you know without going to court whatever
I want to let people use my first thing
which without competitors to just
stealing it aside from you know
obviously using my thing which kind of
says my name on the cover or something
like that so I really want to what I
want to protect is the secret how about
something really fast right and the
continued to say any program is the same
size or any surface of the same size so
isn't any cool but you know something
for once he had to do that using just
obfuscation I mean you might try some
other technique like proofs but
occasionally it's like doesn't have that
much overhead what you would do you
would get your fasting and that a little
bit of Fisk a she would still start but
it doesn't seem to address this kind of
application sure yeah so if at some
point we get amazing obfuscation schemes
and then you could do that amazingly
efficient but for the moment we have
some really positive fist occasionally
soom you guys so so this thing you have
amazingly pacification I still don't see
confiscation consult my application so
she would have something amazing the
cost i mean how it going to use it he do
to the station to actually probably say
that you're going to protect right
because I mean let's say you're just as
any to program sources you know which I
equal is slow you're not going to tell
here I mean there is not a problem which
is equally slow and like the fastest guy
in the market so how am I going to
protect my this young saying
not exactly yeah i mean i io always
starts of two programs in what you want
to say is that the obfuscation center of
the mere indistinguishable and you're
saying that you have one super fast one
and maybe there's nothing else that's
super fast I just haven't really thought
about that situation yeah so I don't
know the answer running time is part of
the elephants you know it's a novel
program run slower than any cousins make
the leap of faith okay so another pretty
easy application of Io is a witness
encryption so the idea and witness
encryption is that you want to encrypt
some message so that say only someone
with a proof of the Riemann hypothesis
hypothesis can decrypt it okay so you
know some more formally you encrypt a
message relatives to some statement and
you can decrypt it if you happen to have
a witness that that state for that
statement so there's no real secret key
in the system per se it's just that if
you happen to have a witness for that
statement then you can decrypt okay and
what we want in terms of security is
that encryption of m0 and m1 are
indistinguishable if it's the case that
this statement is not in the language
so here's how we create it from IO you
start off with a program that does sort
of what you would expect it gets as as
input purported witness and will output
the message m if w is in fact a witness
for the statement X otherwise it will
output Bob so consider that program and
you put io around it of course that's
going to be your big ciphertext so you
know you just feed your witness into it
and now pops the message if it's valid
on the right side you have a program
that always outputs bot okay uio that
these two things are computationally
indistinguishable if it's the case that
the X is not in the language right
because there's no satisfying witness so
that's how you prove the security if
their witness encryption scheme ok we
just wanted that if X is not in the
language that encryption of m0 and m1 or
in the student indistinguishable ok no
real guarantees if it happens to be the
case of X's says so clear
I kind understand the technical part of
what what does it give you what's good I
don't know maybe you want to encrypt you
know a bank account number or something
if someone you know solves reminded by
hypothesis or something like that I mean
you just have a language that verifies
the proof of you have to write the proof
in some formal language it verifies it
and if it's true and then just in this
I guess maybe that is asking I mean
let's saving Krypton there's something
we believe is true we just care about
the group at P naught equal to NP or
something like that so here you know if
you everybody believe it's true can just
put identity function and satisfy your
definition so it's like it does not
there is a thing that you really need to
know the proof like this maybe that's
what that is asking I don't know yes it
does not really things that you really
know the proof let's say if everybody at
all sites in the language you can just
put a dainty function something um yeah
so it doesn't work for that situation
but formally or something you have more
doubt about it it's interesting telling
membership is a problem yeah yeah so
that has lots of applications i mean sun
for statements that we believe are true
is
okay so all of the above applications
are maybe a little uninteresting in the
sense that they have relative security
so for best possible obfuscation all I
could say is that the office keishon as
good as any other for restricted use
software it's you know depends on the
quality of the restricted interface that
you wrap around the program for witness
encryption there's no guarantee
witnesses in the language so obviously
we want to create crypto systems that
have sort of more absolute guarantees
and to get that we sort of need to we
typically need to make an additional
assumption like the existence of one-way
functions you would kind of think that I
oh being an extremely powerful object
that it already implies one my
conscience not exactly so as Amit said
yesterday if P equals NP then
indistinguishable obfuscation exists
just because it's easy to provide kanaga
canonical form to your program you just
provide the first program
lexicographically that provides that
functionality okay so it doesn't just
straight out and ply one-way functions
but there is this result that I 0
implies one-way functions if what we
think is true that NP is not in BP be
the proof is a pretty simple I'm just
what am I going to make my one-way
function about just the office keishon
algorithm ok so my one-way function f of
X is going to be an i/o obfuscation of
some programs e that's just
unsatisfiable everywhere it's just a
program that always output spot right
and X is sort of the Random randomness
that I provide in the obfuscation
algorithm ok so I'm just so again f of X
is justin is just an i/o operation of
this this fixed program Z the Random
randomness I use in the obfuscation is
the input X
okay so why is that a one-way function
well first of all imagine a world where
I switch Z with a circuit that is also
unsatisfiable well then I Oh says then I
can't distinguish between these two
worlds and so if an adversary can invert
the one-way function here it should be
able to invert the when my function here
it's still going to invert with respect
to Z because that's that's what it's
supposed to do ok so the adversary will
still be successful here because it you
know these two worlds should be
indistinguishable by 0 C 1 and Z have
the same functionality so now imagine
that instead I put a circuit in there
that is satisfiable well then the
adversary Canton Berg because there
doesn't exist any X such that this is
why to here is is an obfuscation of c2
because the set of obfuscation sub C 2
is just two disjoint from the set of
obfuscation zuv Z because they have
different functionalities ok so this
gives me a way to tell whether a circuit
c is satisfiable or not i just feed it
to this this inverter and depending on
its success or not he'll tell me whether
it's satisfiable or not that proves the
claim perfect functionality
what do you mean by non perfect it could
be that the obfuscations of c1 and c2
have some tiny tiny intersection very
low probability thought the skater
doesn't preserve and this proof I mean
again there might be some way to extend
it to this case but what I'm talking
about here is perfect okay they're
probably going to be lots of cases like
this where like I mean they're seriously
they're about a hundred papers on the
applications of obfuscation I'm not
going to know all the details so just
you know shout out if you have to know
the answer to some question okay alright
so now i'm going to give you another
simple application which is a way to get
public key encryption from witness
encryption the scheme is pretty simple
the public key is just going to be the
output of a PRG on some secret key this
is like the world's fastest key
generation algorithm for a public key
encryption scheme I just use a PRG it's
a length doubling
okay so I'm going to use encryption
scheme I'm going to use my witness
encryption and i'm just going to encrypt
relative to the statement that there
exists some pre image of this public key
and to decrypt well I have my witness
which is the seed how do I prove the
security of this well first of all I
have my encryption of m0 and 0 where the
statement is with respect to the actual
public key now I'm going to switch the
public key to just be a perfectly
uniform string you can't tell the
difference by prg security here there's
probably if this is a perfectly random
string there's probably no pre image
with respect to the prg so it's
unsatisfiable so i can replace my
encryption of m0 with m 1w by witness
encryption security and then finally I
just got back using prg security back to
my up my valid public key
yeah that's it so we didn't even need I
oh here I mean it gives us and waited
construct one my function and Vanessa
Griffin but it's not necessary we have a
witness encryption scheme mmm yes yeah
this is just from witness encryption
so there are other cool applications of
just witness encryption like identity
based encryption attribute based
encryption for circuits secret sharing
for monotone and p access structures and
so on okay so those were kind of the
layup applications and now I'm going to
get into kind of techniques you know how
we use I oh and security proofs to prove
the security more complicated objects
okay and there's sort of two main
techniques 1 i'll call shell games of
secrets in another is punctured programs
yes it's some okay so it's basically so
you have a monotone function f and in
basically every string that satisfies
this monotone function f corresponds to
a set of players that should be able to
recover the shared secret so you have a
string of zeros and one so you look at
the guys I mean this is a bit string or
end players if the guys corresponding to
the ones in the string they should be
able to combine their shares to get the
secret
alright so she'll games with secrets
okay so here's kind of a thought
experiment I like to have these deep
thought moments you know kind of like
you know can I mind understand itself
you know that sort of thanks so here's
kind of a thought experiment so imagine
that you have some program p one that
uses a secret key sk one but there's
some totally independent secret sk to
that it doesn't use it doesn't contain
it doesn't know about right and on the
right you have the flip side there's
some program p2 that has sk2 but it
doesn't know anything about sk one but
for some reason these programs are
completely functional equivalent so uh
so that means that if you put io around
them there should be computationally
indistinguishable so my question is does
either obfuscation reveal the secret key
sk1 or sk2 ok answer is no of course so
you can clearly see that p1 hides sk2
because it's not there and the flip is
true but down the other end the x io the
two programs are computationally
indistinguishable so we can say that p 1
also hides sk one because it's you know
it's similar to p2 the obfuscation of p2
so this is the 22 key technique of
nowhere young and it just shows that
both secrets are HID then you might
complain that well ok that's kind of
silly I mean you have a secret key
that's not used what does that mean what
can you do with this with this concept
that seems kind of useless turns out
it's not so useless so before I get into
how it's used let me first remind you
about fhe because I'm going to use it
here in a second so fully homomorphic
encryption so you have some data that's
a
unencrypted you might have a circuit
that's unencrypted and obviously you can
evaluate the circuit on the other data
it might be the case that the data is
encrypted with an fhe scheme or even
that the circuit is encrypted with an
fhe scheme and what you can do with the
fhe scheme is that you can evaluate that
circuit on the encrypted data and you
get an encryption of C of X other
variants of this you can evaluate an
encrypted circuit on encrypted data
using universal circuit you still get C
of X encryption of C of X evaluate the
encrypted program on the unencrypted
data same thing ok so really what I
wanted to get to is that in the next
slide we're going to use an encrypted
program that we're going to evaluate
Tong unencrypted data ok so this is a
one of one of the promises that I have
to fulfill for a mint of describing you
know how do you bootstrap io4 nc1
circuits died 04 general circuits so
this is what we're doing here and so
current fhe schemes have decryption
algorithms that are in NC 1
okay so here's a I'll describe to you
what the obfuscation of the general
circuit is going to be so I some general
circuit see what I'm going to do is I'm
going to first of all and cryptsy under
fhe public key PK 1 i'm going to encrypt
it again under pk2 then i'm going to
provide a gnarly obfuscation which is a
sort of a conditional decryption
algorithm what does it do exactly well
it takes as input some value X and a
couple of ciphertext and a proof and
what it does is it I mean it has
hardwired these improved the encryptions
of these two original circuits and what
the proof is supposed to prove is that
what I did to get c1 is I evaluated this
first encrypted circuit on the input X
and what I did to get c2 as I evaluated
the second decrypted program on X okay
the proof should prove that and if that
is in fact the case that all the steps I
did all the steps correctly to get these
ciphertexts then you know output the
decryption of the first cipher text
under sk1 otherwise it outputs pot
because it's unhappy
so that make sense so I mean if I jump
through all the hoops and I actually did
what I was supposed to to compute these
two ciphertext then it really should be
the case that the first ciphertext
encrypts C of X under pk1 exact second
ciproxin cup C of X on your piqué to
write
verifies this is an actual proof it's
not an argument if the proof verifies
then that should actually be true that
these are encryptions of the same value
yeah
uh
no I mean the proof doesn't really have
I mean it's just kind of a like a the
proof can be like a transcript to the
whole computation that's used to laugh
you like yeah I mean I didn't send it
and say it doesn't include it I mean you
can go ahead and include it it's just
going to be a long transcript of the
entire computation that's used to derive
c1 and c2 from the original ciphertext
well I mean you're proving a statement
about c1 and c2 you asking about the
little c1 and c2 right yeah well it's
just it just bet it's much faster or
shallower to verify this statement than
to actually run the computation of
yourself the thing that's going to use
it yeah I mean I guess I could just have
the proof include it and yeah you just
think i'm missing your point
yes it's going to be a really long proof
because it's going to be basically as
long as the entire homomorphic
computation but the point is that this
proof is can be very shallow like
basically you you you express the entire
computation as a circuit say and you
have to prove that for each gate I
computed it correctly and so you have
different blobs and the proof for each
gate and you checked the wires between
the gates are consistent and all of this
can be verified in to buy an NC 1
circuit and very shallow depth sergej a
sub I is encryption on under the peak e
i o co as a message so damn cookies so
what is easy once it tues a sec okay
this yes and yeah this is a big big c
sorry I guess I'm that's an issue
okay so so everything here can be done
in NC 1 verifying the proof and doing
the fhe decryption so we can use our i/o
office cater for NC 1 so why is it gives
of this is NC 1 because just well I mean
the top that's just what do you use here
it's you just I mean you express the
entire computation is a you have just
gates you have little blobs in your
proof for each gate and you just improve
that all the gates you perform correctly
that all the wires and between them
adjoining gates are consistent so highly
parallel and because the corruption is
parallel yeah yeah so all this can be
done in NC 1
okay so one thing I want to point out
about this program is that it doesn't
have sk2 it's just a it just decrypts
the first cipher after verifying the
proof it just says okay now I'm just
going to look at the first cipher text
and decrypt it with sq1
okay so this is what we have in the real
world and I've just sort of highlighted
the sk1 and ciphertext one aspect of it
now if you imagine a different world
where instead the conditional decryption
algorithm had sk2 and decrypted the
second ciphertext with that well I claim
that these two programs have completely
exactly the same functionality because
either the proof verifies or it doesn't
okay I mean if it doesn't the output
spot that's as the same in both cases if
it does then it's actually the case that
the two ciphertext C 1 and C 2 encrypt
the same exact value so they have the
same exact output in that case also
all right yeah so you know by the
previous argument I can at least prove
here that so there's a program here they
uses sk1 it doesn't know about sk2 and
then the flip side and their
computational indistinguishable so I can
at least say at this point that these
programs hide sk1 and sk too but that's
not really what I want to prove right I
want to prove that I have an
indistinguishable obfuscation scheme for
circuits which really has more to do
with the encryptions that I provide of
the the circuits rather than the
particular secret keys so but I want to
kind of bootstrap this fact to prove
that i get i oh so okay it doesn't
contain this case whatever all very
index that it contains a public in wave
in the proof and the public is like
created from the secret key so why
should it identity oh let's just go over
the proof and so yeah so you'll see
there okay so here's the proof suppose
you have two circuits c1 c2 the same
functionality all right so I'm going to
create a few hybrids aren't oh god what
happened you ok so wherever all these
down arrows are those are subscripts ok
so like this is this is like an hybrid
subscript circuit you know then bet be
one ok so at least arrow has some
connection to subscripts I'm a little
afraid of what will happen later on
oh god it's horrible to use the way I
just let me try to go with it here ok
I'll describe it in words so you can
mainly focus on my words ok so what we
have over here is an i/o obfuscation of
c1 ok what that means is that that both
of the encryptions the fhe encryptions
encrypt the circuit see one ok and and
inside the obfuscation I use the key
seek sq1 and over here I have an IO of
c2 so that means both of the encryptions
encrypt situ and still sk1 is used
because that's just the cannot you know
sk1 is used in the obligation ok so i
want to get from there to there so so
here to respond to your question so when
i'm in the first hybrid what I'm going
to do is I'm going to change what is
encrypted under public key to in this
world only sk1 exists we don't know
anything about secret key to so we can
say that the semantic security of the of
the encryption scheme I can change
what's encrypted under public key to so
what I'm going to change it to is
circuit two so now circuit 2 is
encrypted under pick it
okay next I'm going to change the secret
key that's used inside the obfuscation
ok so both of these circuits have the
same functionality so i can say that the
the same result is going to be decrypted
i get the same encryptions of the same
values under public key one in public
key to so if i switch to secret key to
the functionality doesn't change and I
Oh says that this is an
indistinguishable and then I just keep
going like that so next at this point
secret key one is nowhere to be seen so
i can change what's encrypted under
public cube one and i change that now to
circuit 2 then finally i do one more i
owe such the the secret key under which
you decrypt because it doesn't change
the functionality so x ì óù security
this is also in this equation
okay so that's kind of how the shell
games of secret technique use it is used
to kind of go back and forth between
using different secret keys and changing
other parts of the program and
eventually you're able to traverse your
way over to where you want to go
yeah this isn't and this is exactly what
I was proving I mean I just wanted to
first of all give you some intuition
that at least secret key one in secret
key to or hidden and then this fact is
sort of kind of leveraged to the stuff I
didn't understand is the first IOC why
is it the same functionality and in the
next like the first year this one why is
it the same culture it's the yeah so
these two circuits have exactly the same
functionality and so that's so what you
get at the end the final encryption
after you evaluate the fhe it's still
the same thing
okay so that was a bootstrapping io for
NC 12 I 046 you have one more slide
that's going to have some these errors
in it there aren't too many problems
okay that's okay do you have to how you
how do you construct fight it's just a
it doesn't have to have any zero
knowledge properties it's just a real
actual proof so you just have you just
lay out the entire computation you did
express it you know as I said in terms
of the circuit in terms of gates it's
just a real real proof and you feed that
whole thing whole transcript to the
computation into the of us to that
obfuscation and it's able to verify it
in a parallel sort of way that's that's
sort of the key
okay so another application of this
shell games is a functional encryption
so the idea and functional encryption is
that you have some Authority who
generates a master public key and secret
key and this authority is able to
distribute keys for functions okay so f
1 is a function f 2 is a function for
some reason these receivers are entitled
to get secret keys for these functions
these functions might describe the
policy under which that user particular
user is allowed to decrypt for example
or it might describe some sort of
redaction function that for that
particular user then some sender comes
along and uses the master public key to
create a ciphertext that that encrypts
in value X and what the receiver should
get are there particular functions of
that X sometimes it's nice to look at it
as sort of a delegation schemers to kind
of compare it to fully homework
encryption so you know in the cloud
scenario and fully homomorphic
encryption you like to send your
encrypted data the cloud can compute
whatever function it likes on your
encrypted data and send it back to you a
functional encryption the cloud or
whatever is sort of committed to this
particular function that it can compute
on your data and then it could
ok so the to define security a selective
version of the game is that the
adversary selects some two messages the
Challenger creates the public key enzyme
cypher text and the adversary can make
key queries a subject to this obvious
constraint because if he asked key
queries that didn't satisfy this it
would allow him to easily distinguish
what was encrypted so the adversary can
make P queries like that and finally the
adversary guesses what was encrypted
okay so how do you get functional
encryption from IO so first of all you
create some just public key no fhe here
pke pairs speaking one so forth then you
have a crs for a special type of proof
which i'm not going to describe at the
moment i might say a little more about
it later and then the encryption scheme
is kind of similar to before when i
encrypt x i ee encrypted under the two
public yees and i provide a proof that i
encrypted the same value under two keys
and then the decryption key for F is
just something that it gets is input the
deciphered the double cipher text and
the proof that checks that these two
things indeed encrypt the same value if
that's the case then it decrypts the
result applies the function f and
outputs
okay so ya da ya my way now alright ok
so what sort of hybrids are we going to
have we're going to you know basically
doing that do the same sort of thing
we're going to use I oh security to
change the secret key that's used inside
the obfuscation and we're going to use
semantic security to change what is
encrypted here so we're actually going
to have hybrids where x1 is encrypted
here in x2 is encrypted here for example
and the reason that I need this crazy
proof is that I'm gonna in the hybrids
I'm going to prove something that's not
true I'm going to prove that these two
things encrypt the same value it's just
that this is a special proof that
provides an escape hatch for the
particular cipher texts that I've
created in these hybrids the particular
challenge ciphertext ok so then this you
know proof allows me to prove only true
statements except for this one statement
that i want to fudge on and this type of
proof is indistinguishable from a proof
that just doesn't allow that sort of
sort of escape hatch so really the proof
is sort of exactly the same except for
that aspect i have this alternation
between using a PKG security and I oh
security and this is would be exactly
the same as before except that when I
try to use I oh security I'm act in fact
encrypting different values here x1 and
x2 and so I can't there's no I can
actually provide a real proof that these
that these two things can encrypt the
same by you
so what I need to do is I need to use
this as a statistically simulation
soundproof to go to a world that allows
that has a proof system that allows that
one escape hatch that I want to use in
these hybrids and then I just do the
same thing as before okay so I where I'm
encrypting different values here the the
proof system makes an exception for that
case and allows me to pass and and then
once that's the case I mean I can do a
proof and I oh security holds here but
because the functions because if in the
Selective security game for the
functional encryption scheme I can only
make queries that evaluate to the same
thing on the two messages and so even
though these are different messages the
output will always be the same
seven cents well a [ __ ] fat but it
doesn't work again I just want to make
sure we try but it doesn't work so if
this were an absolute proof system where
I'm supposed to be proving that I'm
encrypting the same values under the two
different public keys I wouldn't be able
to provide a proof here because in this
hybrid I'm actually encrypting X 1 or 2
the first public key next to under the
second so i use this crazy proof system
that allows me to create a fake proof
for this the particular challenge
ciphertext that I'm creating at that
point in the proof so some of the
functionalities preserve now this
business simulation sound tools it is
preserved because that you're saying the
proof is actually incorrect on some polo
if I regret no the proof is incorrect
but the two x's do have the same output
value on direct always at the point yeah
so when i switch cheese I mean I decrypt
X 1 over here if I use this secret key I
decrypt x 2 over here if I use this
secret key in the next hybrid but in the
functional encryption security game I'm
only allowed to make key queries on
functions that that are consistent that
you know they have the same evaluation
and the two messages and so the output
of the scription will be the same
okay so that was kind of the playing
shell games with secrets second you can
now I want to go over punctured programs
okay so i have to admit that the
punctured programs technique is probably
a little more useful than the shell game
so secrets one used a million times over
so okay so what is a punctured program
so i'm just going to say that this PT is
a punctured program at T if it's you
know just evaluation is the same thing
at pee everywhere except t we're just
output spot and basically the idea of
the puncture programming strategy is
that I mean first of all I want to try
to show somehow I mean I'm being very
vague here but the general strategy is
that I want to prove that these two
programs you know perhaps if this is a
component in some outer program that the
overall programs maybe have the same
exact functionality and therefore the
iOS of them are indistinguishable and
then I want to also show that the
adversary needs p of t to win the game
but he can't get it in this case because
it's punctured a tee
so sigh and waters have a sort of nice
description of it so the idea is to
alter a program which is to be obviated
by surgically removing a key element of
the program without which the adversary
cannot win the security game but in a
way it does not alter the functionality
of the of the program alright so kind of
the the key punctured program that will
be using over and over again as the
punctured PRF ok this is a the punctured
PRF if it's punctured a tee I can give
you a key Katie Katie that allows you to
evaluate the PRF everywhere but t ok and
wherever if I give you that key it
should even be pseudo random at the
value of T ok it's a pretty easy to
create punctured PRF even from ggm so
you all know and love ggm gosh yes ok
it's obviously a superscript but
yes
all right all right so you all know and
love GTM so you have a length doubling
prg which you know given some seeded up
its g0 of our g one of our and then
basically the PRF on some string X is
that you just go left to right down this
binary tree defined by this by this prg
depending on the bit of X right so now I
want to puncture the PRF so that the
user can't evaluate this particular PRF
at this particular value of T what I do
is I just provide enough material from
the binary tree that allows the person
to evaluate everything else so I give
the user this value after that he can
evaluate this whole subtree of the PRF
and give them that value all the one-off
values and then using those and it's
only log logarithmic and size this is
basically k sub T ok it's not pretty
nice and compact in valuate everywhere
except team ok so now I want to create
public key encryption using a punctured
PRF I already described public key
encryption from i/o and one-way
functions before from witness [ __ ] shin
but it wasn't really what we intuitively
would like to do so if you dippy and
hellman sort of described sort of what
you would ideally like to do is just
obfuscate the encryption algorithm take
a symmetric cipher obfuscate the
encryption algorithm provide that
obfuscation is the public key anybody
can crypt but you know for some reason
people can't decrypt
if you just add enough you know dummy
variables blah blah blah maybe that
maybe that works so for example let's
take a stream cipher okay you could try
to do that but you would not be
successful because a stream cipher [ __ ]
Shin is its own inverse so that's not
going to work so if you provide an
encryption of encryption and decryption
of the same exact algorithm right okay
so it doesn't work in that case but
let's just change the stream cipher just
a little bit so so but instead of
outputting are here I'm going to output
a PRG of our and I'm putting peered G
applied to our here also so obviously
decrypt by taking that applying the PRF
to that getting the message
okay so obviously it's kind of harder to
go in the reverse direction once you
plied apply this prg to that there this
is the Sahai waters actual scheme so
this is this is it this is the public
key encryption scheme so it has this one
has super fast decryption okay so it's
just basically the evaluation of a PRF
ok now I'm going to prove security hmm
there was a blue this thing that doesn't
work you gives you a sponsorship you
just use the regular PR else it doesn't
matter what you use here because
encryption and decryption are exactly
the same algorithm because so if I
provide you an obfuscation of the
encryption algorithm that's can also use
that to decrypt so so you think sittin
in to waste puts your part instead of
art and some cool you made this sneaky
move to function prl oh yeah okay Mina
Mina sneaky move also yes where do
puncture the Snicket you borrow yeah
yeah yeah allow me to cover story
ok so now I'm going to prove security
all right so here's the ciphertext right
so so I have this you know I have this
value here that which is just a PRG
you've some randomness ok so is my
cypher text right there's the prg of
some randomness and then and then it's
just the PRF evaluated that at that
initial seed ok so that's the ciphertext
for a step this should look pretty I
guess familiar first step is just to
make tea uniform prg security ok so now
it's uniform ok so now now I kind of
like before it's it's probably not the
case the tea isn't in the image of the
PRF almost certainly it's not the case
ok so this PR is PP RF here is never
going to evaluate on on this new tea
because this is it's just not in the
image of G so I can without changing the
functionality of the program I can
puncture the PRF at T because it's never
going to evaluate it there and yeah so
instead of and everything's the same i
just use this punctured PRF key inside
there
sense and so that's indistinguishable
bio security because I didn't change the
functionality with overwhelming probably
buddy okay so okay so now I've done that
well by PP by the punctured PR security
i can replace so i still have this value
in the ciphertext C I mean I still put
this value in the ciphertext it's not
inside the obfuscation anymore but it's
still the case that this challenge
ciphertext is masked by the PRF value
evaluated at T so now I just want to
replace that with something completely
random so I can do that because
punctured PRF security says that this
just looks random if I only have a
puncture key
okay so now everything's just random so
that's it
make sense
so that was a punctured PRF another
technique I want to talk about is a
complexity leveraging this is often used
in and proofs so the strategy is that
typically start off with a scheme of
which you can prove selective security
so you try to guess which input the
adversary will in some sense attack
which input okay and if you happen to be
correct that in that case I you know
you'll be able to prove that you can use
the adversary to break i 0 or the
punctured PRF security okay so in other
words the adversary and this slit the
adversaries advantage in the Selective
game is less than its advantage or not I
0 plus P bunch of the earth okay but in
a lot of cases of course I want to prove
adaptive security I don't want to force
the adversary to commit to some
particular value attack beforehand so so
what do i do well I just try to guess
which value if I'm the Challenger which
which I have a serial target I'm correct
with probability you know whenever two
to the N or two to the K right and so in
that case I can show that if you look at
the adversaries advantage in the
adaptive game that basically its
relationship to the the selective game
is that the two to the K difference the
loss factor there right because because
I guessed
okay so so in other words the
adversaries that advantage in the DEP if
game is less than 2 to the K times some
stuff related to IO or the puncture PF
say okay and then you just you boost up
the security parameter until this to to
the cage doesn't matter anymore so if
you have you know incredibly strong I oh
and punctured PRF security this 2 to the
K doesn't matter and the adversaries
advantage in the adaptive game is
negligible so it makes sense so if you
look at the PRF for example so the
number of possible inputs to the pump
gpf is really small so it's only you
know 10 bits you can definitely amp up
the security of the PRF so that you get
you know as much security as you want
even though they because the security is
related to the size of the key not the
size of the input so you can just boost
up the security as much as you want and
then I oh also you can just sort of
boost the parameters of the scheme so
that's it dwarfs the the size of the
input
so so intuitively I use you kind of try
to get security at one point and you
just use this argument to say that you
get security basically all points that
you care about so okay so for example
you can get a constrained PRF so I
described a punctured pft to you though
it was a punctured at one point but
let's suppose that I want a PRF such
that i can give some key K sub C that
allows someone to evaluate the PRF at
all exforge C of X is one receives
arbitrary and for all unsatisfying X you
want the the punctured PRF property that
it looks pseudo-random so I mean we
can't just you know puncture function
puncture puncture because they're an
exponential number of points that we
want to eliminate
okay so what we do instead is is we just
provide an IO of this this program but
you know if see if x is 0 output pod
else I'll put the PRI value function
well we use the bug if you you know
believe in proof so you should probably
I mean you should use the punctured BF
because that's going to be we're still
going to puncture and it appear in the
proof ctrs the punctured part comes in
the proof or already in the construction
because in the construction what's the
difference in pitches use the pura the
proofs i will plug in the pprs no i mean
it needs to be the same PRF I guess so
needs to have the property being a punk
sharable yeah you mean thank you i need
to use a hug sure a bow yes okay yeah
look into construction it's a PRF if the
puncturing happened to the proof right
yeah the puncturing just happens in the
proof but I mean it has to be a PRF and
the real scheme that has the property
that in the proof you can you can
puncture it yeah yeah so G James good
but if you're going to use a yes and in
the skin will become insecure them that
you get it posted a yes is not
functional that which sounds like
something weird right yeah that would be
interesting but on the other hand I have
no idea how he would puncture a yes so
it seems kind of hard yeah is no
punchable something okay so so how am I
going to prove the security of this
thing well let's suppose that I pick a
random t such that T just evaluates to 0
okay let's just assume that I can do
that I mean it might be a very sparse
set but you can artificially boost it so
it's not a sparse set and so let's just
say that I can sample some random tea so
should it's unsatisfying well then
obfuscations of these two things should
be indistinguishable one I it son
punctured and here it's punctured at T
so if I look over here I mean there's no
nothing about tea over here so I mean
that you know the adversary is going to
pick some some value to 24 John you know
there's nothing about tea here so with
probability 1 over 2 to the N is going
to pick the actual tea that we care
about right so i divide by 2 to the N
and these two things are in
indistinguishable up to this epsilon I
Oh factor okay so that means in this
world also yeah adversary what pics tea
with some some noticeable probability
okay and if he in if he doesn't in fact
pick this value and the outputs the
evaluation of PRF at this particular tea
then I've broken ppf security so yeah I
should probably find some point of stop
I might go a few more minutes
okay so you can do not only constraint
PR FS but constrained signatures
basically the signature looks exactly
like a constraint at T looks like a
constrained pfft you just have to
provide some verification algorithm for
it so you just want the property that
for all X that are satisfying you can
use this box to sign that value
otherwise not okay so for example you
could give like a mobile agent you know
the ability to sign on a particular set
of messages so with that satisfy this
particular circuit in the sick signature
will have the property that it looks
exactly like a signature by the original
signer which is kind of cool it's not
some you know music or you know don't
you know it just really looks exactly
like a signature of the original signer
you can also use this for delegation so
if you want some assurance that c of x
equals one then you can have the cloud
produce a signature using this box for
you on on that on x okay so what's the
scheme I mean it's as I said it's
basically the same the signature is the
same as the PRF you have a verification
algorithm here which uses a one-way
function applied to the PRF I you okay
which is kind of funny so how would I
verify this well I mean I get some
something it's some signature which is
purportedly the evaluation of the PPR f
is some value the one one-way function
is public I just apply f to it and I
check if it matches the output of that
and it's kind of similar to before I
just pick some random tea that's
unsatisfying okay and hybrids are a
little more involved so on the left side
I do exactly the same thing I did before
I puncture the prf key there and then i
use the punctured POF key to sign on the
right side I actually I puncture the PRF
key also and I hardwire the value that
is supposed to output for that
particular tea okay so if it gets input
T it just bypasses the evaluation of
this function it just immediately
outputs with this science are coded in
there okay so that's obviously the same
bye-bye I oh security right now I just
change what's hardwired 40 from from
this value to f evaluated at some random
well that should be indistinguishable by
PP RF security now at this point if if
the the adversary actually forges on T
he's found a pre-image of this of this
value and he's inverted the one-way
function because that's just a random
value now
okay so I if you just go through all the
Epsilon's basically again you can use
complexity leveraging to show that that
this interesting secure as long as the
security of the PBR f the i/o scheme and
the one-way function are enough so here
you you're hoping to address the
fortunes of ones that you function yeah
so so again yeah if you start off in
this original case where I before I've
done all the hybrids there's nothing
about t here so it's just there's a 1
over to the end probability that he's
going to pick T 2 for John and then that
that's that world is indistinguishable
from this world over here where I have
all sorts of information hidden you know
about t do need some exponential
security / iya iya ya
yeah so I mean it's you know a lot of
these thing I'm not really worrying
about sub exponential security these
things I mean it's a good problem to get
rid of that assumption and all sorts of
protocols but I'm going to be kind of
fine with it this position okay so
you're saying non-deterministic versions
of these things there's a witness PRF
that takes his input you know statement
and witness it all put the signature if
it's satisfying and there's a sort of a
non-deterministic version if signatures
are sort of an Idzik argument that where
you get a signature on the value X
assuming this relation is satisfied so
this is statistically zero knowledge
because the proof is just a signature on
X a signature on the statement X it
reveals nothing about the witness
okay there are lots of papers on
constrained prf sand on near in the omer
and yeah a few people have a paper on on
that yes
ok alright so i'll stop here